residents in the Pacific Northwest may
soon be paying a lot more in taxes
to fight a man-made climate change
process which many people say has never
been scientifically proven as you can
imagine some of those people are
fighting that plan correspondent Dan
Springer fills us in from Seattle
tonight when it comes to greenhouse
gases and their impact on the planet
President Trump has said only that he
will pull the u.s. out of the Paris
climate agreement which aims to reduce
emissions as a way to stop global
warming but West Coast states are
driving in the opposite direction with
efforts to tax carbon this is both an
economic benefit for the state of
Washington it is a job creator jobs in
the clean energy sector are growing
twice as fast as the rest of the economy
Washington state's Democratic governor
wants to tax residents every time they
fill up at the pump heat their homes or
plug in their electric vehicles
businesses like Boeing that compete
internationally would be exempt to hit
to residents and small businesses 3.3
billion dollars over four years the
money would go to green industries
you're not just subsidizing clean energy
or helped the environment you're also
subsidizing a big expansion in
government bureaucracy which does
nothing to help the environment British
Columbia was the first in north america
to tax carbon in 2008 the results mostly
good emissions are slightly down even as
the population and economy grow but they
also cut taxes to make up for higher
energy costs California already has a
cap-and-trade program while Oregon
lawmakers consider a similar plan it's
all an attempt to change behavior when
you have pollution going up into the
atmosphere for free that's a market
failure and a carbon tax corrects for
that market failure within the market
the fate of the carbon tax bills here in
the Pacific Northwest is uncertain
meantime a similar movement is forming
in the Northeast a bill introduced in
Massachusetts would also tax energy use
the residents there we get a rebate at
the end of the year
Bret Dan stringer in Seattle Dan thanks